six one seven eight three zero 4750
we've got a lot of calls stacked up
we'll try to get to a few more to one
five we'll take a call from two one five
next who's this I was on your show about
a year ago were you yeah I would the guy
was ranting about nineteen of August I'm
sorry you were doing I was a guy who was
worried about that peter voss being
appointed oh well your concerns were
warranted okay basically I'm a Jewish
man one of my biggest concerns recently
has been seeing the increase in
right-wing rhetoric eugenics rate
superiority and how that's moving away
from you know at the online little
dungeon of [ __ ] and festering into like
the mainstream like the mainstream media
yep it seems like they were somewhat
normalizing the rhetoric of Richard
Spencer by presenting him as some
well-spoken like business guy instead of
what he really is which is like so I'm
nicely dressed and not the SOB you know
yeah and it's like I'm just wondering
like do you ever worry that this okay
you ever worry that something like that
happened in Nazi Germany could happen
here right so listen let me put that
last part aside just for a second right
so a couple different things number one
the interviews with there are some
interviews with Spencer that are
concerning and I don't know if you saw
my interview with him and of course I
don't treat him like he's some
intellectual uh who has anything other
than a premises right hold on one second
Brian let me see if I can lay out my
thoughts here yeah so I think that it's
important if you're going to interview
Spencer that you're prepared for the
interview and I believe in responsible
plat
I don't believe in just like a haphazard
umbrella deep platforming simply for the
sake of the platforming at the same time
he has no right to speak at a college
that doesn't want to have them that's
not violating his free speech rights
whatever so people can make the decision
that is good for them and and hopefully
people will be responsibly prepared to
talk to the guy to your earlier point
about the rise of the anti-semitic
rhetoric yes I'm very very concerned as
someone who is ethnically and culturally
but not religiously Jewish I see it and
I've spoken out about it not only in the
United States under Trump doesn't matter
that Trump's daughter converted to
Judaism he can still provide cover for
really really horrible people like for
example when you say there were great
people on both sides when one side with
Nazis that's that's not good
we're seeing the white nationalism in
Europe also rise I've also pointed out
and I don't know if you're aware of this
Brian but I've pointed out anti-semitism
as a blind spot in some circles on the
left the cozy relationship between some
of the women's March organizers and
Louis Farrakhan right I mean that that's
a despicable Alliance that should be
completely denounced it's crazy to me
how quickly normalized and I've also
just made videos just trashing these
white white supremacist idiots because I
just kind of get a kick out of it you
know because it's like I look like them
my skin colors the same as them I think
they're just coming it really gets under
their skin when you kind of look like
them yeah and you're just calling them
out on their crap yeah well Richard
Spencer would argue that you and I are
not actually white right we are I'm
guessing you're Ashkenazi Jewish not
Sephardic because your name's Brian but
what what do I know
we are not white in the worldview of
Richard Spencer Iranians are a complex
one for people like Richard Spencer our
Iranian zweite it's not really it's it's
a whole crazy world and yeah I do worry
about the the normalization of it for
sure appreciate the call Brian thank you
all right thank you
interesting point although it wasn't it
took a little bit to get to it but I
think it's an interesting point it's one
it's
I've been following very very closely